THE HELL IS MARK? MURPHY DOING
IT IS COMPLETE BULL CRAP
OBVIOUSLY, THEY DO NOT KNOW
WHO THEY'RE DEALING WITH AARON
RODGERS. THE TYPE OF GUY WHO
READS THIS AND GOES THIS
FREAKING
A SS
BEEP. I BET YOU AARON. RODGERS
WENT OUT AND WORKED HARDER
THIS WEEKEND BECAUSE HE GOES,
MAN, I CAN'T WAIT TO GET TO
GREEN BAY AND JUST TOTALLY
RUINED
MARK MURPHY'S LIFE. HEY, UP
YOURS, I'M HERE AND I'M BETTER
THAN EVER.
UP YOUR BUTT
JOBU. AARON RODGERS IS NOT
NUMBER TWO.
UH-OH, I KNOW AARON RODGERS IS
NUMBER THREE. THAT GUY
YOU'RE DEFENDING YOU DROPPING.
ALTHOUGH HE WAS WASN'T, HE
WAS NUMBER THREE LAST YEAR,
HE'S HOLDING STEADY AT NUMBER
THREE. HE JUST BEEN
LEAPFROGGED BY
A MUCH YOUNGER AND APPARENTLY,
ACCORDING TO YOU MUCH, NOT
MUCH BETTER, BUT BETTER
ENOUGH. SO ANYWAY, ROGERS IT
THREE.
JOSH ALLEN AT
TO GO AHEAD. SAY, I THINK WE
CAN FIGURE IT OUT. NOW
MAYBE WE CAN FIGURE IT OUT
BECAUSE WE KNOW WHO
NUMBER ONE OR SAY NO. NUMBER
ONE IS THAT'S FINE,
BUT ROGERS, THREE
ALAN TO, LET'S FOCUS ON ROGERS
BECAUSE I RECALL DISTINCTLY
LAST YEAR, WHEN YOU
INSTALLED ROGERS AT THREE YOU
WERE CONCERNED
THAT BASED ON THE 2019 FILM
EVEN THOUGH THE PACKERS WENT
13 AND 3 AND GOT THE NFC
CHAMPIONSHIP.
YOU SAW SOME SIGNS OF
SLIPPAGE AND OBVIOUSLY, THE
PACKERS DID TO, OR THEY
WOULDN'T HAVE DRAFTED JORDAN
LAW. IF THEY SAW SOMETHING
THAT MADE THEM THINK IT WOULD
MAKE SENSE. NOW,
TO TAKE A QUARTERBACK.
WHAT DID YOU SEE DIFFERENT
BETWEEN?
ROGERS?
2019 AND 2020.
AND WHAT ABOUT
THAT WASN'T ENOUGH
TO CAUSE HIM TO MOVE HIGHER
THAN NUMBER THREE. WELL,
LISTEN, IT WAS IN A PHENOMENAL
YEAR. HE IMPROVED IN A LOT OF
WAYS FROM THE THINGS THAT WERE
NEGATIVE FROM 2019,
YOU KNOW. HONESTLY,
I THOUGHT HE ACTUALLY
MOVED AROUND A LITTLE BIT LAST
YEAR, BETTER, COMPARED TO
2019?
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THAT. I
THINK HE WAS A LITTLE BIT MORE
MUSCULAR AND TWITCHY
THAT WAY WE'RE IN
2019. HE GOT INTO THAT YOGA
TOM BRADY AND IT'S LIKE, NO,
YOU'RE NOT. THAT KIND OF
ATHLETE OR THAT GUY
YOUR DIFFERENT BODY TYPES,
EVERYTHING LIKE THAT.
SO,
SO, THAT WAS BETTER,
BUT I THINK MORE THAN ANYTHING
MIKE, HE LET IT RIP A LITTLE
BIT MORE LAST YEAR NOW, I
THINK HE COULD STILL LET IT
RIP A LITTLE BIT MORE
TO WHERE HE CAN BE A HAIR
CAREFUL. YOU KNOW AGAIN I
LOOK AT ROGERS SOMETIMES AND
JUST GO
I MEAN
YOU'RE AARON RODGERS YOU COULD
FIT THAT BALL INTO THAT WINDOW
OR YOU THAT GUY'S GOT
HIM BEAT BY A FOOT, YOU SHOULD
THROW IT NOW THERE WAS LESS
OF THAT BUT THAT WOULD BE A
LITTLE BIT OF THE NEGATIVE BUT
I THINK THAT WAS THE BIG
TURNAROUND FROM 2019. REMEMBER
2019. HE HAD THAT
MOMENT.
MATT LE FLORE ON THE SIDELINES
WHERE THEY HAD THAT ARGUMENT
EARLY IN THE YEAR, THAT WAS
WHAT IT WAS ALL ABOUT. HE HAD
A WIDE OPEN IN CUT
AND
MATT LIVERS LIKE
YOU'RE AARON RODGERS, YOU HIT
THAT BULLSEYE EVERY TIME WE
CAN'T TURN THAT DOWN.
HE TURNS LESS OF THEM DOWN
LAST YEAR THAT'S FOR SURE. I
MEAN HE'S A ZEN MASTER.
HE STILL IS SO INCREDIBLE
WITH THE DECISION, MAKING
HIS THROWING
IS
STILL THE GREATEST.
I MEAN, IT'S STILL ONE OF THE
GREATEST ARMS AND
IN FOOTBALL RIGHT NOW IN THE
HISTORY OF THE SPORT,
EVEN AT HIS AGE.
AT THIS MOMENT
AND YOU COULD SEE HERE, I
MEAN, YOU CAN STILL PUSH THE
BALL DOWN THE FIELD
WITH INCREDIBLE EASE
BUT
IT ROGERS IS LESS
THE MAGIC MAN THAT WE SEE
MAYBE MAHOMES AND JOSH
ALAN HE IS GOING TO DO IT MORE
WITH HIS EYES AND HIS
BRAIN AND THEN
AS HIGH-LEVEL ACCURATE
THROWING OFF OF THAT, YOU
KNOW, YOU SAW IN THAT CLIP
AGAINST JACKSONVILLE, I MEAN,
HE DOES A GREAT JOB OF MOVING
THE SAFETY AND EVERYTHING
LIKE THAT. THEY PUT SO MUCH
ON HIM, YOU KNOW, THROUGHOUT
THE OFFENSE AND
AGAIN
AS QUICK RELEASE
IS HE THROWS A PERFECT
SPIRAL. I MEAN THESE THROWS
RIGHT HERE. I MEAN, COME ON.
IT'S LIKE THERE'S A MAGNET TO
VALDEZ SCANTLING AND THAT'S,
THAT'S HOW SPECIAL IT IS.
BUT YOU SEE HERE
TOO. IT'S A LOT MORE IN THE
POCKET, YOU KNOW, THEN ROGERS
OF FOUR AND FIVE YEARS AGO,
BUT
IS RECOGNITION OF DEFENSE HAS
GETTING THE TEAM IN THE RIGHT
PLAY. AND THEN OF COURSE,
I MEAN ALMOST NEVER MISSES A
THROW ALMOST NEVER
THAT'S WHERE ROGERS ARE
SPECIAL AND
HE'S STILL AN INCREDIBLE.
KIND OF QUARTERBACK.
LISTEN IT HURT MY SOUL TO MAKE
HIM NUMBER THREE,
BUT FOR MY MONEY, ONE
AND TWO ARE REALLY FREAKING
AWESOME. ARE YOU KIDDING ME
WITH THAT THROW RIGHT THERE? I
MEAN, THAT'S
AMAZING LIEVABLE, IT'S
UNBELIEVABLE. THE PROBLEM IS
THE GOT THE TWO GUYS WERE
GOING TO TALK ABOUT BEFORE
THAT
HAVE LIKE A MILLION
OF THOSE TYPE OF PLAYS AND
THAT'S WHY THEY'RE IN FRONT OF
HIM, BUT ROGERS STILL
AMAZING
AND CERTAINLY ONE OF THE BEST
QUARTERBACKS IN THE
GAME.
AND THE REIGNING MVP
AND TO BE THE MVP,
CONSIDERING ALL THESE OTHER
GREAT QUARTERBACKS
THAT OCCUR EARLY. IN THE NFL
THAT IS
INCREDIBLE
AND AND IT'S WHAT'S MADE THE
DRAMA EVEN MORE COMPELLING.
YOU DON'T SEE THIS
FROM THE REIGNING MVP.
EVERYTHING SHOULD BE PERFECT
WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
REIGNING MVP, BUT AS AARON
RODGERS SAID A FEW WEEKS BACK
PLAYING THE WAY DID LAST YEAR
THROUGH A WRENCH
SHOTS. MESSED UP MADE ME
BELIEVE THAT
THAT THEY WERE
WERE READY.
AFTER 2020 GOING INTO THE
SEASON
TO MAKE THE CHANGE AND NOW
THEY CAN'T. AND NOW THEY'VE
RECOGNIZED THEY HAVE
THEY HAVE CREATED A MONSTER
THAT IS VERY GOOD FOR THEM ON
THE FOOTBALL FIELD BUT A
HEADACHE FOR UPPER MANAGEMENT
OFF THE FOOTBALL FIELD. YES.
OKAY. SO
HERE, LET'S GO FORWARD. YEAH.
WHAT-WHAT CAN ROGERS DO IF
ANYTHING
THIS YEAR
TO GET YOU TO MOVE HIM HIGHER
THAN 3 OR
IS 3 AS HIGH AS HE'S EVER
GOING TO BE
BE GIVEN ALL
THESE OTHER GREAT QUARTERBACKS
IN THE LEAGUE. I THINK HE
COULD STILL BE,
YOU KNOW, TOO.
YOU KNOW, MAYBE ONE
BARRING INJURY. YEAH, CAN HE
MOVE UP BARRING INJURY TO ONE
OF THE TOP GUYS? I THINK HE
COULD, YES, I DON'T KNOW IF HE
CAN BE NUMBER ONE ANYMORE.
I DON'T KNOW. I DON'T, YOU
KNOW, THESE
MAHOMES IS FREAKING SPECIAL.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT ELSE TO SAY.
IS AWESOME. AS I THINK AARON
RODGERS IS, AND IS THE
GREATEST QUARTERBACK I'VE EVER
SEEN. ESPECIALLY WHEN IT WAS
HIS PRIME. I MEAN, MY
HOLMES'S, HE'S ON TRACK TO BE
THAT GUY
TO AND HE HASN'T EVEN STARTED
THE PRIME OF HIS CAREER. AND
THE PROBLEM IS THE OTHER GUY
GUY THAT'S IN FRONT OF US.
UM JOSH ALAN, IT'S THE SAME
THING.
SO THAT'S WHERE IT'LL BE
TOUGH. BUT YEAH, HE
HE HE'S CAPABLE OF THAT TYPE
OF PLAY AND LISTEN, IF
SOME COACH IN THE NFL CAME
TO ME AND
WHEN YOU'RE WRONG, I THINK
ROGERS IS ONE OR TWO,
I WOULDN'T GO. OH, YOU'RE
CRAZY. THAT'S STUPID.
I UNDERSTAND THAT REASONABLE
MINDS. MIGHT SEE THIS
DIFFERENTLY. I GET THAT.
I DO
BUT YEAH FOR
YOU KNOW
ROGERS HAS BECOME
LESS THE ATHLETIC FREAK,
RIGHT?
AND A LITTLE BIT MORE OF
THE ZEN MASTER.
UNBELIEVABLE THROWER,
MANIPULATE YOU WITH EYES AND
BRAIN AND EVERY LOOK AT THIS
PLAY, THIS IS A GREAT ONE.
MATT, CASEY FOUND THIS, IS
THIS JUST SHOWS YOU LIKE
MEMBER THIS PLAY FROM THE RAMS
GAME AND THE PLAYOFFS.
THEY'RE GOING TO SEND DAVANTE
ADAMS IN MOTION. HE'S CHECKING
IT ALL OUT BECAUSE HE WANTS TO
MAKE SURE HE'S GETTING THE
RIGHT COVERAGE FOR THIS
TRICKY LITTLE PLAY WHERE THEY
DO THIS YOU KNOW. ALRIGHT SO
SEE HE GOES THAT WAY.
EVALUATES THE COVERAGE. OKAY
YEP I THINK I GOT WHAT I
WANT. THAT'S
PERFECT.
ALL RIGHT, LET'S GET SET UP.
HERE WE GO, LET ME MAKE SURE
EVERYBODY KNOWS EXACTLY WHAT'S
GOING ON
AND
YOU KNOW AGAIN HE'S IN THE
SEND DAVANTE ADAMS BACK
ACROSS NOW IN A HURRY
BECAUSE HE'S GOING TO WAIT, I
GOT IT.
AND I THINK THEY'RE GOING TO
BE CONFUSED HERE AND WHATEVER
ELSE. AND OF COURSE THEY ARE
AND THIS IS WHERE ROGERS IS
SPECIAL TO NOT ONLY THE
QUICKNESS OF HOW HIS BRAIN
WORKS.
BUT THEN THE QUICKNESS OF HOW
HIS BRAIN CAN CONNECT TO HIS
RIGHT ARM. I MEAN THERE'S
NOBODY
MAYBE DAN MARINO, THAT CAN GET
THE BALL UP AND OUT OF
THEIR HANDS QUICKER THAN IT.
LOOK AT THAT. A BLITZING
SAFETY OFF THE EDGE. HE GOT
THE SNAP AND GOT THE BALL
OUT AND REALLY DIDN'T EVEN
HAVE TO THROW IT SIDE ARMOR.
DO ANYTHING CRAZY AND
STILL DO IT? YOU KNOW, THAT'S
WHERE TO ME. HE'S GONE NEXT
LEVEL AND THAT'S WHERE GREEN
BAY IS REALLY PUT THEMSELVES
TO YOUR POINT. MIKE EVEN
MORE IN A IN A CORNER
HERE, BECAUSE YEAH, HE'S
PLAYING AWESOME.
AND THEY FINALLY HAVE
WIRED THE ROBOT LIKE WE TALKED
ABOUT WITH DEREK CARR AND
GRUDEN TO WHERE HE'S
KIND OF MASTERED THE OFFENSE.
AND HE'S THEY HAVE A NICE
COMBINATION.
WHAT LAFLEUR DOES AND HOW
ROGERS WORKS
AT THE LINE OF SCRIMMAGE? AND
THAT'S ALSO WILL BE A DOWNFALL
OF THE FOOTBALL TEAM. IF THEY
DON'T HAVE THAT ASPECT OF
ROGERS, YOU KNOW, BEHIND
CENTER
AND I LOVE THAT CLIP BECAUSE
HE
LULLS THEM TO SLEEP.
YES. ADAMS IS GOING RIGHT TO
LEFT
HO-HUM AND
AND THEN IT JUST IT'S LIKE
THE PLAY BEGAN BEFORE THE PLAY
BEGAN.
ADAM SPRINT'S BACK ACROSS.
HE'S ALREADY INTO HIS ROUTE
AND THE BALL HASN'T BEEN
SNAPPED YET AND YOU SEE THE
GUY
BUT JALEN
RAMSEY CAN'T GET ACROSS THE
FORMATION.
YEAH, COVER HIM THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO
SWING IT AND ALL THAT
BUT I BELIEVE THAT'S WHY JALEN
RAMSEY'S YELLS AT
END OF THE PLAY BECAUSE THEY
WERE SUPPOSED TO SWITCH
WHERE HE NOW GETS. YOU KNOW,
THE STATIONARY GUY AND THAT
GUY THAT WAS OUTSIDE
HAS TO GO OUT TO DAVANTE
ADAMS,
BUT THAT'S THE BEAUTY OF
ROGERS. HE UNDERSTOOD THAT HE
KNEW THE BLITZ THAT WAS
COMING. HE KNEW IT ALL,
SO ONCE HE SAID THAT MOTION,
LIKE YOU SAID, HE GAVE HIM THE
OLD OKEYDOKE. IT WAS LIKE,
OKAY, NOW FLY ACROSS SAID HOT.
BOOM, AND THAT'S, THAT'S WHERE
HE'S AMAZING. AND INCREDIBLE
DOWN THE FIELD THROWER.
BUT
ALSO
AN INCREDIBLE SHORT BALL
THROWER TO WHERE HE COULD
THROW.
OH, THOSE BUBBLES. SCREAMS OR
SWING PASSES TO AARON JONES
OUT OF THE BACKFIELD AND THEY
NEVER BREAK STRIDE AND
THEY'RE ABLE TO CAPITALIZE ON
ALL THERE. IT'S TH
E GATOIN BEDE  AFTER THE CATCH T